hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts protective effect of a
novel noncompetitive interleukin 1
receptor biased lien in an infection and
inflammation induced preterm birth as
well as in fetal injury and
developmental outcomes presented by dr.
sylveon stem Taub a professor of
pediatrics
ophthalmology optometry and pharmacology
at University of Montreal an adjunct
professor of pharmacology at McGill
University and the director of
ophthalmology research at the University
of Montreal I'm Suzy Valdez and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
that appears on the screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on the help desk
bot button located at the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use that ask a question box
and let us know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
offers continuing educational credit
click on the continuing education credit
tab located on the right top corner of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit without
further ado please join me in welcoming
our presenter today dr. sylveon shemtob
I will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir good day everyone my
name is Sylvia shemtob
and I will be talking to you about
prematurity and labor and adverse
outcomes
prematurity is a major cause of
disability later on in life
approximately 15 million children are
born premature in the world 1.1 million
of these died unfortunately in the
United States alone the cost of
prematurity amount to approximately
forty billion dollars a year and so far
in the last thirty years the rate of
prematurity has essentially not changed
at all there are many causes to preterm
birth but the major cause for preterm
birth early in gestation in other words
before 28 weeks until the ages of
viability of the fetus which is
approximately 22 to 23 weeks gestation
the main causes apply to inflammation
and in this process various components
are involved in triggering this
inflammation either alarm ins which are
generated endogenously or bacteria which
actually trigger the formation of
certain compounds which then activate
specific receptors which will trigger an
inflammatory process which then activate
and induce a series of proteins called
uterine activation proteins and these
will trigger preterm labor and preterm
birth if we actually see on the
following slide we actually can
appreciate that
a number of inflammatory genes are
expressed on chorionic amniotic Coral
Yanik membranes in from patients that
were had a labor versus dull those that
did not have labor as shown in green and
in red you can see actually that a
number of inflammatory genes are
actually induced under the labor process
in a very important study which was
reported by Roberto Romero where he
investigated the rate of inflammation
mm-hmm
whether it was microbial or sterile
inflammation or no inflammation at all
at different gestational ages and very
clearly on that slide number five what
we can appreciate is that the great
majority of labor that occurs early in
gestation is associated with
inflammation in that contrast with labor
that occurs much later nearing term in
gestation as you can see when we're
under 30 weeks of gestation 85% of the
labor is associated with inflammation
whereas when you're near term
sixty-three percent are associated with
no inflammation despite this very
important association between
inflammation and labor so far the only
therapies that we have affect only labor
per se but not the inflammatory process
that precedes this labor none of the
treatments that we have right now
address uterine inflammation
on the following slide we can appreciate
I see a cascade of events that actually
emit are initiated by inflammatory
stimuli which then stimulate specific
receptors called toll-like receptors
which then induce the formation of
pro-inflammatory cytokines and
chemokines and these then lead to an an
influx of neutrophils macrophages and
and t-cells these will then produce more
inflammatory mediators such as
prostaglandins and oxytocin receptors
and that will then facilitate the
process of my own mutual contraction
rupture of membranes and cervical
ripening which will all lead to the
expulsion of the fetus the current drugs
that we have only affect the latter part
in other words the myometrium
contractility that's the only part that
now is affected by labor but when we
actually look at the efficacy of these
compounds they're hardly efficacious in
very interesting studies that have been
published over the last couple of years
hmm
Benoit has demonstrated that in fact
when we compare for example an oxytocin
receptor antagonist to a calcium channel
blocker in contractility we can only
extend labor by approximately four in
gestation by approximately one week when
we're dealing with labor induction at 23
weeks this is not a major promotion of
gestation to go from 23 to 24 weeks and
hence this actually
begs the question what is actually going
on prior to this and that we need to
tackle these events in order to make a
significant impact in reducing preterm
birth and this is where
anti-inflammatory agents the one that
I'm going to be speaking to you in a in
a short while which is at the top of
that slide slide number seven called red
Vela effect interleukin 1 receptors
other companies are actually going after
other receptors which are for the
prostaglandin F 2 alpha receptor just
below as you can see there's observer
fairing GSK that have an interest in
these prostaglandin F 2 alpha receptor
given their important role in my own
material contractility so on the next
slide slide number 8 we actually
highlight the evidence to support to
il-1 importance in preterm labor and
perinatal injury il-1 is produced by
macrophages by trophoblast by decidua in
response to bacteria and its levels are
very high in labour il-1 amplifies the
inflammatory cascade through a
feed-forward loop that means that when
il-1 is produced it actually acts again
on its own receptor il-1 receptor which
will then trigger even more il-1
production and vice-versa
in other words i oh one feeds itself in
the formation of iowa ayah one
stimulation leads to the production the
induction of uterine activation protein
expression which then lead to
biomaterial contractility and labor per
se an Iowan alone is able to induce
labor
humans polymorphisms of interleukin-1
data of caspase one which leads to its
production as well as a receptor of
interleukin one effect labor and this
actually highlights the importance
therefore of il-1 even in humans or over
in preclinical evaluation interleukin 1
receptor antagonists namely generator
delays labor induced by IL 1 but not by
clinically relevant infectious and
non-infectious triggers of the toll-like
receptors which are activated by alarm
ins and bacteria which lead to the
process of information and downstream
of my own mutual contractility moreover
ion levels increase in the brain during
perinatal inflammation and that has
itself is associated with adverse
effects in later on to the to the
newborn il one also causes brain micro
vascular and parenchymal degeneration
and this is prevented by interleukin 1
receptor antagonist so to date there are
a number of drugs that affect
interleukin 1 activity there these drugs
are Kinneret rolana sept connect in a
map as shown on slide number 9 but these
drugs have a number of adverse effects
and which actually limits their use the
other thing is that actually they have
drawbacks the very large molecule and
the required systemic administration
their immunogenic they're very costly
and very importantly and relevant to
this presentation they do not inhibit
labor triggered by relevant toll-like
receptors tablets slide number 10
when we actually look at the effect of
these compounds they are classically
real on a SEP connect in Amman and
Kinneret
ortho steric inhibitors in other words
that they interfere with the actions of
the natural ligand or they mop up the
natural ligand if it was if it is an
antibody and in slide number 10 one can
appreciate that such a competitive
inhibitor would essentially act on the
ortho steric site where the ligand is
actually sits on and would interfere
with all the signals associated with an
activation of that receptor by the
ligand ideally it would be it would be
ideal if actually we have compounds that
would interfere with some signals
associated with the receptor but then
actually preserve other signals which
may be best left untouched and that
would be the case of allosteric
antagonist as seen on the right side of
the schematic diagram this allosteric
antagonist do not actually interfere
directly with the ortho steric binding
site of where the ligand is acting but
it's actually on a remote acting on a
remote site as a result it affects some
of the signals associated with that
ligand but it actually then preserves
also other signals
hence the advantages of allosteric
modulator
they have an enhanced specificity and
enhance selectivity diminish
side-effects and tolerance and
diminished inter-individual kinetics as
they could be for example peptides and
not metabolized and therefore there are
dependent on mainly renal elimination or
protease elimination they're stable and
are much smaller
hmm slide number 11 so one of the
interesting things that we have done is
that we decided that to look at loop and
hinge regions of receptors and actually
mimic these regions by reproducing a the
peptide sequence of that region and we
did that and in all the conformation in
order to actually stabilize the peptide
against endogenous proteases
as shown on slide number 11 and we did
that for many receptors as you can see
appreciate that on slide number 12 we
did that for prostaglandin F 2 alpha
receptor which is called F P and shown
here on the right side of slide number
12 where we actually looked at device
derived peptides from various juxta
membranous regions of the prostaglandin
F 2 alpha receptor and we identified one
from the second extracellular loop which
is actually circled on that diagram and
that one turned out to be quite
effective and moreover it's at Eve it
was even actually taken into clinical
trials and has shown to be effective and
that's where it's at right now but it's
not a comp it's a compound that we
licensed mm-hmm to accompany another
example is for vasopressin 2 receptor
for diabetes insipidus we utilized the
same approach and were able to find a
peptide a small peptide which was
affected the same happen for the
prostaglandin e2 ep4 receptor for acute
renal injury and more recently we also
showed it for the chemokine CCR 2
receptor and acute inflammation we then
applied this approach to more to differ
type of receptors not g-protein coupled
receptors as is the case for fpv to our
84 and CCR 2 but actually for tyrosine
kinase receptors as interleukin 23 and
interleukin 1 receptor and we were able
to show that moreover this technology
was actually tested by a company and
they tested it on eight other targets
and shown it to be effective so let's
move on to slide number 30 the folk
because a focus is really going to be on
il-1 given the importance of il-1 and
inflammation and for the sake of this
presentation on preterm labor and
adverse effects of the fetus so on slide
number 13 we actually have depicted in a
ribbon-like manner the interleukin 1
receptor subunits the turqoise is the
interleukin 1 receptor 1 the gold is the
interleukin 1 receptor accessory protein
1 actually
interleukin 1 which is in magenta purple
interacts with interleukin 1 receptor 1
then this unit changes its conformation
to adapt itself to the interleukin 1
receptor accessory protein and the
interleukin 1 receptor accessory protein
then triggers a signal and results in
induction of a signal triggered by the
interleukin 1 so using a similar
approach of actually identifying
peptides from loop and hinge regions we
actually identified a number of
different peptides for the interleukin 1
receptor but I will focus on one which
is actually of the sequence of red Vela
ry TV e LA and it actually comes from a
region which is duck JAXA membranous
between the interleukin 1 receptor
accessory protein and the member
and is shown in blue we actually labeled
this compound you will see in this
presentation 101 point 10 we labeled it
like that and I will go I will use these
two terms red Vella
or 101 point 10 so Ravello actually
stands for the sequence of the amino
acid arginine tyrosine threonine valine
glutamate leucine
elleny based on this we therefore wanted
to understand if rubella actually
affected signals triggered by
interleukin 1 interleukin 1 triggers
through two major canonical pathways the
NF kappa-b pathway and a map kinase
pathway so we actually tested verified
if actually 101 point 10 affected the NF
kappa-b pathway and interestingly we
utilized three different approaches to
investigate this we looked at I Kappa B
activation we looked at head blue cells
where actually the NF kappa-b promoter
is controlled it is actually a the NF
kappa-b promoter controls alkaline
phosphatase secretion and we looked at
nuclear translocation of the P 65 unit
subunit of the NF kappa-b and in all
cases 101 point 10 did not affect this
but in fact this turned out to be a very
desirable effect because in preterm
labor the newborn is actually highly
dependent on innate immunity which is NF
kappa-b dependent and because NF kappa-b
is important for in you know visual
answer it would be best actually left
untouched and 101 point 10 contrary to
generator actually does not inhibit
il-1 induced activation of NF kappa-b
whereas Kinneret suppresses it on slide
number 15 we actually appreciate that
however 101 point 10 does affect the map
kinase pathway and as well as the role
kinase the role a kinase pathway and
this is in a dose-dependent manner we
could see p38 tuned kinase C Jun and
relay activation which are actually
suppressed by 101 point 10 and as well
as carat moreover it is important to
point out that this pathway the the map
kinase pathway which then actually lead
to an activation of a p1 and the role
kinase pathway inhibition of these
pathways interferes with prematurity as
can be appreciated on slide number 15 on
the right part of the histogram on the
right side so we have a very interesting
now effect which is called biased ligand
activity of 101 point 10 it biases the
signal such that it actually interferes
with the io1
induction of signals but only for the
Rho kinase and map kinase pathway but it
actually leaves untouched the NF kappa-b
pathway but this is however sufficient
actually to interfere with the
pro-inflammatory gene expression this
isn't shown on slide number 16 hence a
small all the pet died is a selected by
a signaling allosteric modulator of the
interleukin 1 receptor it is also
effective in several inflammatory models
as we'll show you in a few
on slide number 70 so based on this very
pronounced efficacy of 101 point 10 on
the map kinase pathway and the Rho
kinase pathway preserving the NF kappa-b
101 point 10 was actually shown to be
effective inflammatory bowel disease in
contact dermatitis and rheumatoid
arthritis in osteoarthritis and hypoxic
ischemic encephalopathy of the newborn
and the adult and ischemic and
retinopathy and in preterm labor and
from here on as of slide number 18 I
will actually focus on preterm labor so
for that purpose we utilize three
different models of information into
preterm labor preterm birth you could
see on slide number 18 il-1
lipopolysaccharides
LPS and lipo t colic acid LTA that was
administered at 16 and a half days of
gestation and 101 point n Kinneret or
vehicle one were administered
immediately at the same time and then
what we monitored is actually whether
these animals deliver preterm or not the
timing of birth well the first thing
actually we see is that upon
administration of interleukin 1 on slide
number 19 to our naked eye without any
microscopes interleukin 1 causes outfit
what we see here is actually uterine
horns and on these uterine horns in the
vehicle you could see the very nice
color of these uterine horns with the
pups inside the uterine horns mm-hmm
upon administration of interleukin 1 is
one who become very adamant as' engorged
and inflamed but in the presence of red
Vela
or 101 point 10 you could see actually
the disinformation
is markedly suppressed in these animals
on slide number two 2120 we appreciate
actually that indeed rid Bella or one
1.10 is able to suppress a number of
genes in the uterus interleukin one is
increased interleukin 6 is increased up
in the vehicle treated animals
interleukin 8 mm t9i and as well as a
prostaglandin synthase type 2 but this
is all suppressed all these inflammatory
mediators are suppressed by 101 point n
whereas Kinneret does not have any
significant effect on any of these genes
curette which is actually the
commercially available compound also
does not have any effect on information
flam Ettore mediators in the newborn
mouse itself so this was done actually
systemic inflammation in blood of the
newborn Mouse at birth and you can see
in here interleukin 1 is increased but
it is suppressed by 101 point 10 same
thing with IL 6 IL
prostaglandin $0.80 h 2 etc where s
Kinneret does not suppress this on slide
number 22 we can appreciate that red
Vela 101 point 10 is able to prevent
creature prematurity induced by IL 1
induced by Lipper Ally portal colic acid
and induced by lipopolysaccharide the
lipoic acid mimics a gram positive type
of bacterial infection whereas the lipid
polysaccharide mimics a gram-negative
type of infection which then actually
triggers the toll-like receptors in both
cases for the LTA as well as the LPS in
all cases Ravello is able actually to
signal
evidently diminish the rate of
prematurity induced by these triggers of
inflammation
whereas Kinneret is not able to do so
moreover on slide number 23 one can
appreciate that even one we administer
red Vela a few hours after the induction
of inflammation and we selected four
hours because two to four hours is the
peak of information after the
polysaccharide you could see that
actually on on slide number 23 on the
timing of delivery graph you can see
that we can bring it with red Vela
essentially to the same thing as the
control whereas in the case of the
vehicle were really prematurity there is
prematurity in the vehicle treated
animals so all in all what we have shown
so far is that red Vela acting via the
map kinase Rakharo kinase pathway is
able to suppress inflammation in the
uterus in the pumps and all and it
prolongs gestation in these animals
prevents preterm birth but what happens
actually to the fetal and newborn
outcome slide number 24 so we actually
pursued these studies along with a
colleague of ours dr. David Olson and
Sarah Roberts and what we see in here on
slide number 25 is that is the number of
animals that's that are born alive so
newborn survival you can see that in the
animals that are treated with
interleukin 1
approximately 30% of the animals
survived interleukin 1 secondary to this
very pronounced inflammation that I
showed you before in the presence of red
Vela we actually almost completely are
able to prevent the cell death and
therefore maintain survival of these
animals whereas Kinneret is not able to
do so and this is appreciated on the
pups that you can see here on after 24
hours post introduction one in the
presence of vehicle on the top images
whereas in the bottom images they're all
actually lies unfortunately you see
lysis of the tissues with blood seeping
onto the cardboard whereas in the
presence of rubella the animals are
actually in good shape and are not lies
they're not bleeding they're not
inflamed so what is the evidence that
interleukin 1 slide number 26 is
involved in fetal and newborn brain
injury because if that were the case
then Ravello would then be a very
interesting target a very interesting
therapeutic candidate for to target
interleukin 1 and preserve not only
against prematurity but also the outcome
of prematurity and which is the
inflammation associated fetal demise
indeed interleukin 1 concentrations are
very high in preterm infants who develop
neurological disability specifically in
chorioamnionitis lipopolysaccharide
induces high levels of interleukin 1
concentrations in the brain this is
liver polysaccharide administered during
gestation interleukin 1 elicits neonatal
brain injury and interleukin 1 receptor
antagonism prevents inflammatory brain
injury
so based on that we therefore tested
whether antenatal inhibition of
interleukin 1 using Ravello would
actually preserve fetal organ integrity
mainly that of the brain are and also
other neural tissues of the retina so on
the slide number 27 we appreciate that
with villa 1 administered to Danza
actually suppresses inflammation up in
in the brain it does so for interleukin
1 it does so for interleukin 6 it also
does it for TNF and in 2012
so therefore with Vela is actually able
to diminish the inflammation induced by
LPS in the brain mmm unfortunately the
administration of interleukin 1 leads to
2 to the to the fetus to intrauterine
horn interleukin 1 leads to a damage of
the brain resulting in a decrease in the
weight of the brain as you could see on
the slide number 28 on the top left hand
corner there's a histogram of brain
weight upon I interview can one you have
100 milligram decrease in the brain
weight in other words over 30 33 percent
decrease in the brain weight Ravello is
able to preserve this Kinneret partially
as we've shown interestingly this is
associated with actually the effects of
intro of rubella with a preservation of
the micro vascular integrity so by doing
so then you're also able to preserve the
parenchymal integrity in these
animals we then decided if that is the
case that res Vella is able to preserve
the micro vasculature and the brain
waiter in then we should be able to
preserve as well the function of the
brain so we tested that utilizing a an
approach called visual evoked potential
where we actually upon a flash of light
we trigger a response a signal response
in the brain which then can be recorded
in the occipital occipital lobe and we
did that and we can actually appreciate
this very this very effect that
interleukin 1 causes a suppression of
the P to amplitude of the visual evoked
response this is actually preserved by
101 point 10 and to a lesser extent by
kynareth moreover you could see on the
histogram immediately adjacent to the p2
amplitude where it says percent of
affected my son that 100% of the mice
that were actually received until Lucan
wound were affected whereas none of my
son will have received 101 point 10 were
affected important to point out that all
of these studies were conducted in a
double-blind manner Ravello
therefore preserves brain and tell
integrity so one of the questions that
was raised we raised was well does it
cross the placenta does it reach the
fetal brain interestingly we looked at
that and in fact what we did is we
labeled with Vela one 1.10 with FITC and
you can see actually on the slide number
29 that FITC labeled sorryi 101 point 10
labeled with fitc actually um
distributes very nicely to the maternal
side of the placenta but not so much to
the fetal side of the bus
Center and also on fetal brain on the
histogram you can in fact we do not
detect any 101 point 10 significantly on
the in these fetal brain
so essentially 101 point 10 does not
cross the placenta but it does protect
the fetus and walk we'll come back to
that another element that we wanted to
study is actually oops is weather 101
rubella or one 1.10 protects the retinal
vasculature which is actually this is on
slide number 30 which is another neural
tissue since retinopathy of prematurity
is one of the complications of very
preterm birth as is the case with neural
neurodevelopmental disabilities is for
the pre terms and chorioamnionitis for
we could see in here that upon
administration of interleukin 1 to the
dams we actually have an impairment in
vascular development even starting at
the first day of life this is actually
however preserved by 101 point 10 as
well as by Kinneret and one can
appreciate it even more when we add P 15
mm-hmm when at P 15 we could see that
actually a the vascular density is
actually significantly affected by
introducing one but it is not but it's
actually preserved by in animals that
were treated with revell if we know then
look at Ravello another important
element which is could be affected
you could see actually that Ravello also
preserves the choroid which is the
vascular tissue that supports a
photoreceptor nutrient and oxygen supply
and once again 101.9
is able to fully preserve this and
finally along the same lines if that is
the case if one on 1.10 is able to
preserve the vascular integrity of the
retina it should be able to preserve
also its function so for that purpose we
conducted electroretinogram on these
animals and we can appreciate on slide
number 32 that the d-wave of the
electrode which is a function of the
inner retina is significantly diminished
in amplitude by interleukin 1 and it is
preserved by 101 point 10 as well as
Kinneret but Kinneret actually if you
remember does not prevent labor per se
so with 101 point 10 one is able
therefore to prolong the station and
also have a direct effect in preserving
the integrity of the fetal tissues so in
summary when we compare antenatal 101
point 10 to Kinneret on slide number 33
Ravello is able to prolong the station
and prevent preterm birth this is not
the case with clean red red Vella is
able to actually prevent a preserved
neonatal survival this is not the case
with Kinneret it is able to preserve
brain integrity it is able to protect
and I didn't show you this lung and
Frank Amol integrity as well as that of
the gut and as I showed you also ocular
structural and functional intact
so in summary slide number 34 rubella
displays pharmacologic selectivity by
favoring by a signaling it affects some
but not all pathways coupled to introdu
can one receptor specifically it
preserves the NF Kappa B pathway
important and immuno vigilance with val
has been shown in different studies to
exert anti-inflammatory properties and
distinct conditions more relevantly in
this case as it applies to preterm labor
in blinded studies with Vella has been
shown to diminish gestational tissue
inflammation to prolong gestation
induced by different inflammatory
stimuli to enhance boxer vive oh and
improve outcome and to improve newborn
outcomes including preservation of organ
and histology and function and resulting
in normal growth trajectory in vitro and
in vivo studies were confirmed by
separate laboratories and thus with
Vella is a first in class therapeutic
candidate in the prevention and arrest
of preterm birth slide number 34 35 I
would like actually to thank our
collaborators and consultants for this
work that was done and actually included
many people dr. David Olsen from the
University of Alberta in Canada dr. bill
Liu Bell our chemist dr. Sara Robertson
a renowned preterm labor specialist from
University of Adelaide in Australia dr.
Shin knee and obstetrician and scientist
at Shanghai University in China dr. Jeff
keel and dr. Alastair gun dr. Christina
Adams well Waldorf from the University
of Washington dr. David Stevenson from
the Stanford University and other people
were involved in the clinical
development perspective of this
discovery
dr. J Norman Bryan Mitchell Roberto
Romero Emmanuel du jour and Diane Kalina
and we thank you all for mmm this for
this
for your attention thank you and thank
you dr. shemtob
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button
well enter as many questions as we have
time for now so let's take a look at our
incoming questions from our audience
members our first question in dr.
shemtob is is interleukin 1 relevant in
preterm labor and in pre perinatal organ
injury so this is was the essence
exactly of the presentation that in
factor interleukin 1 sometimes does not
seem to appear to be as significant in
terms of amount generated in Korea Corie
amniotic membranes as as is the case for
example for interleukin 6 but
interestingly interleukin 1 is really a
master regulator of a number of actions
associated with in the innate immunity
this is the case for the activation and
the attraction the migration of
neutrophils and macrophages to the
placenta as well as to the uterus this
is the case for the activation of
microglia by interleukin 1 and it also
is very important in triggering the
process of integrating interleukin 6
which then in turn actually establishes
a process by which actually T regulatory
cells are then transformed and inhibited
and
favoring the activation of th 1 and th
17 cells to the in to the detriment of
actually more protective th to type of
cells
so in essence interleukin 1 is important
in preterm labor and it is also
important directly in causing damage to
tissues this is clearly demonstrated by
many other laboratories as is the case
for interleukin 1 adverse effect on
newborn brain and also newborn and
retina
hence introdu kin 1e does play a very
important role in labor and an adverse
outcome to the fetus and newborn which
actually suffers from neurodevelopmental
disabilities as well as other adverse
effects related to prematurity as I
pointed out retinopathy of prematurity
and other conditions such as where
interleukin 1 also plays a role
inflammation and lung resulting in
bronchopulmonary dysplasia
thank you dr. shemtob
and I want to thank our audience members
for their questions coming in and remind
them that any questions not answered
today will be answered via email our
second question dr. shem tov is is it
necessary for an anti-inflammatory drug
to cross the placenta to exert efficacy
yes so this is a very this is a very
good question because one of the issues
is do we need to cross the placenta to
exert anti-inflammatory properties and
as we see from the effect of red Vela it
does not need to cross the placenta it
doesn't in fact it does not cross into
the
fetal percenter cider and it does not
cross into the fetal organs as we've
shown by actually tagging Ravello with
FITC so therefore how is Ravello caught
causing an effect so the likelihood is
that Ravello is most likely affecting
the inflammatory cascade in the placenta
and the Corre amniotic membranes by
suppressing these it reaches actually
these areas it suppresses the
inflammation in these areas
it doesn't need to cross into the fetus
into the fetal side and that is
sufficient actually by diminishing the
inflammation in the placenta to actually
avoid these cytokines to themselves
actually crossing the placenta or
actually being activated on the fetal
side of the placenta and therefore
amplifying the inflammatory process so
if we're able actually to suppress the
inflammation at the interface of the
maternal maternal fetal interface then
we'll be able to suppress this
inflammation and this is actually what
the evidence is shown in this in by our
data so far interestingly Kinneret is
not able actually at the dose utilized
in the clinical setting is not able
actually to suppress preterm labor but
it is able to decrease inflammation in
the brain and also preserve to some
extent adverse effects of interleukin 1
and other triggers of toll-like
receptors which need to interleukin 1 on
the fetal side and the reason why
Kinneret is probably doing this is
because probably Kinneret is affecting
to a lesser extent
the inflammation also on a maternal size
because it does not cross the placenta
and we know this from the work of CV
shear are published about two years ago
it does not cross the placenta therefore
but on the other hand it actually is
able to suppress the inflammation on the
maternal fetal interface and this is
sufficient as well to decrease the
inflammation on the fetal side and
preserve the now it should be pointed
out that of if we actually increase by
the doses of generator to up by 25 fold
what is currently suggested in the
clinical setting then one is able
actually to suppress the effects are the
two to prevent preterm labor induced by
interleukin 1 or LPS and that was also
recently published by arm so therefore
it's not that Kinneret is not at all
able to suppress preterm labor but you
need very high doses of Kinneret to
suppress labor and preterm birth with
camera and therefore you actually put
the mother in a very immunosuppressive
environment thank you doctor same job
our final question that we have time for
today is what is the patient cohort that
would best benefit from rubella without
over exposing patients to that drug
important question in terms so who do we
treat from a clinical perspective who do
we treat in the you know in preclinical
studies we control everything but in the
clinical setting is who do we treat and
I think that this is a a major
[Music]
question that needs to be addressed and
essentially based on discussion with a
number of clinical experts in the field
probably the best thing would be to
treat women that are at risk of preterm
labor and that means women who either
had a previous history of preterm labor
but this was probably not going to be
sufficient to be able to identify your
cohort of patients that are going to be
treatable and hence there is a number of
activity going on worldwide right now to
identify markers of who actually is
going to be delivering preterm if we now
combine will able to combine some of
these markers to identify the women that
are at most risk of delivering within an
egg the next couple of weeks then I
think that this is going to be a major
improvement in the outcome of preterm
birth and I want to highlight that our
colleague dr. David Olsen is actually in
the process of developing a very
interesting leukocyte migration assay
which will unable to detect these women
with a predictive value which is in the
route seems to be in the range of about
90% positive predictive value of
delivering within one to two weeks this
would be actually ideal fibronectin has
often been used until now but
fibronectin has a very good negative
predictive that but a very poor positive
predictor that and i think a combination
of identifying subjects who that are at
risk and subjects that are that
press markers that put them at a
significant risk of delivering soon
these are the patients that would be
best
treated and best benefit from a
treatment such with such a thorough
beauty candidates such as we develop
thank you dr. shemtob
and thank you for your presentation and
for your important research I'd also
like to take the opportunity to think
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May 2018 you'll receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues to me of miss today's live
event that's all for now
and thanks for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye bye